the unblock method encourages us to
understand why we're feeling bad about
work in the first place and tackle the
issue headon imagine you've got a pebble
in your shoe that makes running
particularly painful but you have to run
over to your friend's house in time for
dinner the first solution is the easiest
do nothing procrastinate until the
evening has been wasted miss your dinner
and don't get invited next time the next
solution draws upon the motivation
method that would involve convincing
yourself that the dinner is going to be
exciting and worth the pain of running
you ignore the pain as you race towards
your destination only to collapse on the
side of the Road halfway there the third
solution is the discipline method you've
committed to the dinner and you're the
sort of person who keeps their word so
you run to your friend's house lo and
behold you make it unfortunately the
dinner can't go ahead because your
friend has to drive you and your bloody
stump to the hospital discipline is
freedom you recite to yourself as you
await medical attention what if you took
a minute to think why does getting to my
friend's house seem so hard you would
take your shoe off find the pebble and
remove it and then off you'd run